[Music]
last talked we started planning that
Emmy gown how's the progress going
there's been progress we've been talking
a couple shapes of colors but nothing
nothing is solidified yet which is sort
of fun because I just like I constantly
am inspired by different clubs like
colors and and different designers and
so it's hard it's hard we'll see you
said you're bringing your mama to the
Emmys were you able to also get an extra
ticket for Josh okay so we're that's in
the works I mean my two other sisters
might be coming as well so we'll see I
need some tickets yeah yeah
are you still getting to see Josh Sean
says he still cameraman this year he is
he is he um we see each other you know
whenever I'm working and he's still
texting me like hope you have a great
day I'll see you soon
he's a little he's a little gem only do
you have an amazing offspring
relationship your on-screen relationship
is pretty perfect to Kate and Toby
what's coming up next to them they moved
back to LA they moved in together and
now she's pursuing music so it's one of
those things where you know you and you
move in together and she's starting a
new career there's a lot of dynamics a
lot of things that are going on so we're
gonna we're gonna see the ups and downs
speaking of music you know miss Mandy
was just over here I asked her if we
were gonna get that duet that you and I
have been planning she say she hinted
that some things are in the works yeah I
believe that they are I believe that
they are nothing's solidified nothing
confirmed but I believe that they are
how amazing is that come on come on I
don't even I can't even imagine like is
it gonna be original is it gonna be
covered like what's gonna happen I'm
excited about you pushing for honestly
just this thing with Mandy her voice is
like so pure and just oh just the singer
that would be wonderful
[Music]